alors que la campagne de vaccination
bunce bat son plein de nouvelles
interrogations émergent les personnes
vaccinées contre le coc vide
peuvent-elles tout de même développé la
maladie est ce que l'on est forcément
positif au coronavirus si l'on vient de
se faire vacciner
ce soir on répondre à vos interrogations
avec lucas chopin les cas bon soir sur
la laine pose est donc journaliste à tv
tour suite à un reportage réalisé sur la
vaccination à l'ehpad de brou de
joué-lès-tours sur les réseaux sociaux
plusieurs téléspectateurs se sont
étonnés de voir que les résidents
vacciner avait tout de même contracté le
coronavirus d'où cette première question
lucas le vaccin empêche-t-il d'attraper
le coronavirus non la réponse est claire
non les fabricants évoque environ 95 %
d'efficacité mais celle ci ne se
vérifient que sept jours après la
deuxième injection
il est donc tout à fait possible d'être
positif avant ce délai mais également
après on ne peut pas être protégée à
100%
en général les patients à vacciner et
atteint sont asymptomatiques ils sont
positifs mais pas véritablement malade
le vaccin en pêche principalement de
développer des formes graves de lakovic
19 qui plus est pour le moment rien
n'indique que le vaccin empêche la
transmission du virus
les personnes vaccinées doivent donc
maintenir les gestes barrière deuxième
question le vaccin peut-il transmettre
le coronavirus là encore c'est non non
c'est impossible et je vous propose
d'écouter à ce sujet eric d'où des îles
et le président du conseil régional de
l'ordre des pharmaciens en centre val de
loire
c'est totalement impossible
le vaccin et qui est disponible
actuellement est un vaccin qu'on appelle
à arn messager qui utilise une toute
petite partie du matériel de du virus
donc en aucun cas on peut être malade
avec ce avec ce vaccin n'a pas
activement un vaccin classique nous
injecte des virus atténué ou des
morceaux de virus mais le vaccin contre
la copie de 19 est un vaccin dit arn
messagers c'est ce que confirme et éric
boudey donc avec ce type de vaccin on
nous injecte pas de protéines virales
on injecte de l'acide nucléique un code
génétique qui va permettre à notre corps
de fabriquer une protéine contre
laquelle on va développer des anticorps
à aucun moment on ne nous injecte la
maladie
accent apprend en réalité un autre corps
a créé de la protéine contre laquelle on
doit se défendre c'est nouveau c'est le
premier vaccin du genre appliqué à
l'être humain et on n'a pas assez de
recul pour le moment sur les effets
secondaires mais ce qui est sûr c'est
que ce vaccin ne transmet pas lakovic 19
message est passé
que se passe-t-il si une personne
attrape le virus entre la première et la
seconde injection du vaccin alors des
études ont permis d'observer que la
réinfection à lakovic 19 est très rare
dans les 90 jours qui suivent une
première contamination
la haute autorité de santé en raison du
nombre restreint de doses de vaccins
préconise donc de décaler la première
injection de 3 mois si l'on tombe malade
en revanche pour le moment assez peu de
contre indications s'ils ont attrapé la
coved 19 avant la deuxième injection
on a contacté la haute autorité de santé
elle nous a expliqué que recevoir cette
deuxième injection alors que l'on est
encore infectés pourraient avoir tout
simplement l'effet inverse de celui
escompté faut donc attendre d'être
négatif pour se rapprocher de son
médecin traitant
et c'est avec lui qu'on va décider de si
oui ou non on poursuit la vaccination
est quoi qu'il en soit jamais besoin
d'administrer plus de 12 dernière
question faut-il désormais de porter
deux masques pour mieux se protéger
contre le variant britannique l'a
beaucoup entendu et c'est à la fois vrai
et faux
l'arrivée de variants plus contagieux
que le virus classique a remis en cause
l'utilité de certains masques par
exemple les autorités sanitaires
recommandent de ne plus utiliser les
masques artisanaux même s'ils sont très
jolies et les masque en tissu classique
qui laisse encore trop passer les fines
gouttelettes mieux vaut donc privilégier
l'utilisation de masque en tissu de
catégorie 1 et il consiste en une
superposition de couches coton non tissé
coton et il faut également continuer à
porter des masques chirurgicaux tout
simplement et les masques ffp2 euh euh
pardon sont plus rares et donc à l'essai
de préférence au personnel soignant on
écoute à ce sujet ce qu'on pense éric
boudey alors on a entendu que certains
pays ne préconisait plutôt le masque
ffp2 mais voilà un masque chirurgical
correctement portée est suffisant à mon
avis pour répondre à votre question
superposer des masques va effectivement
réduire les risques de contamination
mais un masque chirurgical
j'ai toutes les quatre heures devrait
être aussi efficace merci merci du cas
pour toutes les explications